get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to spectator out loud
i'm fraser nelson
each week we ask three of our writers to
read their pieces out
this week our columnist lionel shriver
argues that the real determinant of
creative virus isn't race
it's obesity and what makes people obese
that she says is a very separate and
difficult
question simon cooper who's the founder
of fishing breaks
asks whether the return of beavers into
england's river is really something to
be celebrated
and gary pev looks at the downfall of
bulgaria where she was born
and asks why the european union keeps
backing its kleptocratic government
first lana shriver in the uk's capital
city
where do the fewest obese people live
north london the most east london
the weight disparity between largely
white and largely immigrant residents
might seem to concern race but i will
argue
against the tide as right now everything
is about race
that deep down the fat differential
isn't ethnic
the american and british media have
chided for months about higher coveted
fatality rates among minorities
and i've previously cast medical dubai
on the
fashionable claim that these patients
are dying of racism
released last month a statistically
meticulous columbia university study of
some
7000 cases validates my skepticism
as the new york times reported the study
did not
find race or ethnicity to be an
independent risk
factor the researchers did find
extreme obesity to be a strong
independent risk factor
for worse outcomes indeed
when isolated from conditions like
diabetes that
corpus can trigger obesity alone
raises the likelihood of a dire covet
response
by fostering inflammation and breathing
difficulties
the crucial variable isn't race
it's fat patients with extreme obesity
a bmi of 40 or more were almost
three times more likely to die from
covid
than people of normal weight those with
a bmi of 45 or more
were four times more likely to die
and poundage is as perilous for young
people
as for the over sixties
the cross-atlantic correlation between
weight and ethnicity is
awkward a staggering 42 percent
of all americans are obese nine percent
extremely so
the same figure as for the white
majority
the prevalence of obesity among blacks
is nearly 50 percent
among hispanics 45 percent
among mostly east asians only 17
after three hours of digging online
i can only conclude that the british
breakdown of adult obesity by race
is a closely held state secret
uk obesity rates are only widely
available under the combined category of
overweight and obese whose greater
breadth
would have a leveling effect country
wide
about 62 percent black 74
white british 63
mostly south asian 57 percent
and south asians apparently suffer size
related ill health at lower weights than
whites
chinese 35
i can at least verify that in britain
black and pakistani women
are especially prone to wider waistlines
so if you've reached the same quiet
conclusion anecdotally
it's not because you're a bigot at least
not only because you're a big in both
countries
why are blacks especially so heavy
when bringing themselves to allude to
this phenomenon at
all condescending liberal commentators
bend over backwards to remove
personal agency from living with the
burden of obesity
while themselves eagerly embracing fads
like the 5
2 diet as if the privileged
dump fat on unsuspecting minority
neighborhoods
through an underhanded scheme of
corporeal fly tipping
yet many popular external explanations
don't wash the problem is not
food deserts where shops don't sell
greens
the nhs would never want this secret out
but you could credibly thrive on chips
and fried chicken
as long as you called it quits after a
couple of drumsticks
and chuck the rest in the fridge weight
wise
quantity matters more than quality
the problem is not poverty per se
healthy food is not necessarily
expensive
broccoli in the uk cost 50p
an enormous cauliflower a couple of quid
i cook in my regular shop consistently
costs less
than the trolley full ahead mounded with
ready meals
the problem is not poor health education
a 10 year old of any color has figured
out that pizza makes you fat
and lettuce doesn't the problem is not
poor english
because lettuce is low calorie in any
language
and anyone who hasn't understood the
ceaseless impotent
hectoring directives from the mercifully
defunct public health england
has been lucky in the uk
the problem is not lack of access to
health care
because we have the free nhs
an institution so helpless in the face
of rising obesity
the gps are now reduced to prescribing
bicycles i lost my older brother to the
complications of obesity
while writing my subsequent 2013 novel
big brother
i gave fat a lot of thought i don't
believe this
is a racial problem it's a class
problem those obesity figures for
white americans and white britons
disguise a profound
subdivide however ironically given how
much
face stuffing the well-off could afford
most successful whites eat less than
struggling whites
just as they're also far less likely to
smoke
in the west most successful people from
any background
are underprone to overeat
granted i over generalize nevertheless
one key to success is developing a
capacity for delayed gratification
you do your homework before you play
affluent professionals enjoy eating ice
cream as much as anybody
but an attractive healthy body is a form
of human capital
to refrain from polishing off the
haagen-dazs is to protect your
wealth in a larger sense it's an
investment in your future among whites
and non-whites alike
stuck on a social stratum that
cultivates low expectations
overeating constitutes a refusal to
invest in a future
in which this cohort has little faith
my broke demoralized brother ate out of
hopelessness
there's no reason to protect human
capital that's buying you
nothing if the future looks dim
it makes perfect sense to indulge in
immediate gratification
because the kebab sitting on that
takeaway wrapper is the only kind of
gratification
you're apt to see this is not
i repeat not a character failing
it's a sign of rationality oh
other factors pertain like cultural
norms
not only within minority communities but
across the board in both countries
whose cultures have reconfigured the
human proportions
now considered ordinary in the american
midwest for example
chunky has become simply what people
look like
yet at core this issue still seems
teleological
it's fun to eat and it's way more fun to
eat carrot cake
than carrots to refrain from forking all
that cream cheese icing
you need a long-range goal that's more
important than pleasure in the present
too many people don't have one
that was lana shriver and now simon
cooper
the verdict is in hooray for beavers
the rodents that once roamed the
wetlands of britain
hunted to extinction in the 16th century
have been gradually returning to our
rivers for some
years now the first discovered on the
river tay in 2006
had either escaped from enclosures or
more probably
were deliberately and illegally released
into the wild
in england the first were found on the
river otter in devon in 2013.
following a five-year report by the
devon wildlife trust
the environment minister rebecca powell
this month gave them the right to live
roam and reproduce the report's
conclusion
was overwhelmingly positive beavers
attract tourists
and promote ecological diversity their
dams might even help fight climate
change
and flooding in february some of us
concerned with the future of england's
chalk streams
met in a dorset village hall near toll
paddle to offer a contrary for you
the ecological great and the good
natural england
the national trust the dorset wildlife
trust
sent representatives to deliver their
verdict in the name of consultation
chalk streams are often called england's
rainforests
they are unique delicate ecosystems home
to many rare
vulnerable species including watervole
and damselfly
they are the corridor of life for the
atlantic salmon the european eel
the brown trout they are scarce and are
almost
exclusively english of the 225
that exist globally 215 are in england
since their flow is gentle empowerments
where the result of man or nature
can cause serious problems like a block
gutter dams bung up the system
trapping detritus that festers we know
this to be true
because for the past two decades the
environment agency
the eea the government body charged with
protecting the health of our rivers
has been telling us so in response to a
europe-wide initiative
the ea has arranged hundreds of
consultations
and spent millions of pounds to remove
the wears
dams and numerous other abstractions
from our chalk streams
that impede the free flow of water and
migrating fish
beavers of course are all about dams
natural england
the government's advisor for the natural
environment has deemed these
empowerments to be good
in contradiction to the ea in the right
place they are
they can create a healthy wetland but
they will do
great damage in the chalk stream valleys
the river below will become starved of
water
a best of dirty ditch soon the fish
water voles amphibians and insects will
flee or die
beaver dams are nigh on impenetrable for
fish
trout or salmon moving upstream need a
run-up to leap a dam
in fact there is a formula to guide
their efforts
the plunge pool needs to be one and a
quarter times deeper than the dam in
front of it
since a beaver dam is at least four foot
tall
any trout will be able to clear one on
the otter but there's little hope of
that happening on chalk streams which
are typically shallow
but pointing out these negatives does
not seem to have much effect on the
national trust
britain's biggest landowner which is set
on wild releases in the purbeck hills
this will place beavers within a day's
walk of dorset's chalk streams
all the argument is focused on
re-wilding and re-introduction
as if the landscape the beavers once
occupied still exists
it doesn't in the 500 year absence of
beavers
the wetlands of chalk valleys have been
transformed into water meadows
a balanced ecosystem that beavers would
upend as the streams
have transformed from tennyson's
brimming river
to a series of static water ponds prone
to siltation
and deoxygenation with a loss of
spawning habitat
as for a reduction in flood risks a
favorite argument of the pro-beaver
lobby
this has little relevance to a chalk
stream where the rise and fall between
winter highs
and some of those is measured in inches
rather than feet
and the excess such as it is spills out
onto the water meadows like the national
trust
the dorset wildlife trust are beaver
smitten
at some meeting there was an
extraordinary exchange between a trust
representative and a landowner who asked
given that the trust river flowed into
his
why he hadn't been consulted about the
release of beavers
into a three acre enclosure the reply
was tarp
we're a private company so we don't have
to
the deck is stacked against the status
quo because beavers have captured the
zeitgeist
those of us who have concerns have been
treated with the kind of hostility
usually reserved for climate change
deniers
the government's decision about the
river otter proves the point
it is based on an impact study of the
local environment
the report does not ask what may happen
if the beavers roamed to the nearest
chalkstream valley
just 30 miles to the east or examine the
wider effects for fish
wildlife and landscapes very different
to those in devon
and if beavers do cause problems to
short valleys any hope we can get rid of
them as fanciful
if you thought the badger car was
controversial try going after beavers
my view is that natural england should
adopt a precautionary approach and
impose a moratorium on future licenses
for both wild and enclosed releases
until
2030. in that time the beavers on rivers
such as the otter can take their chances
if they thrive without causing permanent
damage the fears of us beaver skeptics
will have proved unfounded
the country has done pretty well without
beavers for 500 years
i don't think waiting another 10 will
make much difference
that was simon cooper and finally gary
pev
my father's faith in communism
evaporated during a summer of
backbreaking work at the docks on the
black sea
like all good young bulgarian communists
he had to undertake a few months of hard
labor during university
holidays unloading cargo before going
back to his studies
he saw then the way the economy worked
or didn't
it was all about gaming the system the
best jobs and most lucrative contracts
went to party members and stooges
he began to work on his escape plan
years later
he abdicated his posting in the middle
east outpost and fled to the west
i often wonder what would have happened
if our family had stayed put
given that my native bulgaria is now a
member of the european union
but it doesn't take very long reading
its newspapers to find out how little
has changed
the conspiracy and paranoia remain but
this time they are aided and abetted by
billions in eu funding
and for as long as those running the
country make pro-eu noises
they don't get trouble from brussels
it's a scandal but few outside the
failing state care
bulgaria has the dubious distinction of
having the highest level of corruption
in the eu
according to transparency international
but only now are the shenanigans
surrounding the current prime minister
boycott borussov an ex-firefighter
finally getting some international
attention
pictures of bordisov sleeping in his
bedroom with a glock nine millimeter
handgun
and bundles of 500 euro notes stuffed in
his drawer have been leaked and sent
around the world
as have recordings of his phone
conversations peppered with profanities
and plots
bodusov has tried to shrug off photos
arguing in effect
that everyone must know that the prime
minister of the most corrupt member of
the eu
has to sleep with a gun his detractors
were out to get him he said
all that was missing was a little boy
next to me but even in a country
hardened
corruption all of this has raised
questions
the focus of the ongoing anti-government
protest is borosov's links to two men
ahmed dhogan who used to run bulgaria's
ethnic turkish party
and dalian pevsky who controls most of
the newspapers
protests erupted last month after it
emerged that government security
services
had been protecting dogan's luxury black
sea compound
cutting off access to the public beach
nearby christo ivanov
a former justice minister who now heads
the anti-corruption yes party
landed a dinghy on the beach saying he
wanted to plant a bulgarian flag in the
sand
he filmed the stunt on his mobile
released it on social media and mayhem
ensued
the main question people are asking why
is borisov allowing taxpayers money to
be
used to provide security to a private
billionaire it's pretty indefensible
but bodisov has found allies in the
transnational european people's party
the biggest grouping in the european
parliament manfred weber
a group leader of the epp released a
statement in support of the bulgarian
government's
fight against corruption with protests
still going on
and bulgarian citizens chanting mafia
outside the parliament
a defiant bordesov somehow secured a 29
billion euro package from the eu
one protester held up a sign that asked
eu are you blind
the most likely answer is that the eu
sees what it wants to see
borisov positions himself as the only
leader who can keep bulgaria on a pro-eu
trajectory
and that seems to be enough for brussels
one bulgarian source who has links to
the eu
tells me borussov is seen as a conduit
into turkey
it is well known in brussels that if
merkel wants to go to erdogan
she can go through borisov he is a
political cab for hire
as long as he keeps saying yes he will
receive his golden shower of euros
the source tells me this might be a
short-term strategy
bulgarians are now asking who else is in
borosov's network
and whether it might include forces
outside parliament that are by no means
friendly to european interests
eu backed plans for a pipeline that
would cut bulgaria's reliance on russian
gas
have been repeatedly impeded by the
bulgarian state and some say russian
interests within the country
julian popov environment minister and a
former bulgarian caretaker government
said that his country offers easy
strategic pickings for moscow
southeastern europe is the cheapest way
for russia to destabilise the eu
for the past 30 years there has been a
vacuum so it's very easy for corrupt
forces to influence things
he says borisov is now under pressure to
resign
but it is far from certain that he would
do so no matter who ends up in charge
says popov the eu
must undertake a much more thorough
examination into strategic corruption
much of the money can be accounted for
on paper but the eu should be probing
who is getting the contracts
and how competent is the infrastructure
that has been delivered
they are rewarding loyalty at the
expense of the rule of law he added
krasen stanchev an economics professor
at sofia university
argues that eu cash is being channeled
to corrupt forces in bulgaria in two
ways
one is by directly distributing funds to
businesses owned by bodisoft cronies
of 200 million euros recently given to
rural guest house owners
much of it ended up being channeled to
friends and families of the government
and political elite
the other channel is national
infrastructure funding which can be made
to look entirely legitimate
a highway construction project will be
divided up into 10 to 20 kilometer
stretches
deterring international companies from
tendering this makes the road more
expensive to build stuncheoff says
it costs three times more to build a
kilometer of highway in bulgaria than in
norway
despite the terrain and price of labour
in norway
and brussels seems happy to look the
other way ivanov suspects that the eu's
tolerance of borosov as its turkey
whisperer
points to a far deeper malaise an empire
is at the point of eclipse when it
allows its border policy to be handled
by local warlords
he said recently somebody in berlin is
making a cynical calculation
a billion more or less who cares as long
as you keep buying the good favors of
borosov
and you keep him stable who cares about
some tips
along the way the interests of ordinary
bulgarians have been forgotten
they still living in a kleptocratic
state and all they
can do is ask why so little has changed
that was guerry pev and that's it from
spectator out loud this week
thanks very much for listening and
thanks to our producer max jeffrey
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound amazon gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator dot co
dot uk
forward slash voucher